[Music]  hello I'm Conan O'Brien last week on my  show I made a promise to my audience I  said that if we were able to raise a  significant amount of money for the  charity event night of too many stars  which benefits people with autism I  would host an entire episode of this  show with a horrible spray tan and my  hair in cornrows well people really came  through for us to date we have raised  sixty four thousand twenty two dollars  and seventy seven cents incredible so  the good news this money will do a lot  of good for a great cause the bad news I  no have to go through with my promise  and do tonight's show bronze and braided  idiot yes I am Andy yes I am  [Music]  mm Warner Brothers Studios  [Applause]  [Applause]  dog  hi Richard tonight's episode  [Music]  a terrible plan  [Applause]  here he is  [Applause]  I  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]